hey there I thought it would take a
little time to answer some questions
that have been coming through on social
media so let's just jump right in
um can you shed light on how some people
who are never good at their jobs get
promoted okay so there are two reasons
why people who are never good at their
jobs get promoted uh the first one is
um they're completely unqualified for
everything that they're doing but
they're really good at managing up
they're really good at faking it and
eventually
um that'll collapse and they'll get
found out
um and that's the real world but
sometimes sometimes the leadership is
actually looking for different skill
sets sometimes being good at your job
doesn't mean you're actually necessarily
good at leading other people to do their
jobs and sometimes you don't have to be
the best at something to be good at
leading other people to do it so
sometimes we're looking at people who
are you know they're not the top players
not the best at their jobs but maybe
leadership sees something in them which
is why they want to put them in a
leadership position so if you're
thinking about your own career as well
yes absolutely you want to be good at
those hard skills the skills that about
being good at your job but it's the
human skills as well which is learning
to listen or get help others Thrive
around you that may more likely lead to
your promotion than simply hitting all
the numbers I acting very cynical of
companies that only promote People based
on if they hit the numbers because then
they're just performance driven only and
if they completely ignore all the human
skills it actually can do damage to a
team so don't assume that's because
somebody's not the top player or the top
performer on the team that they aren't
worthy of promotion
um and if somebody's just good at
leading up managing up well
here's another question how do you
define safety how important is
psychological safety in a culture and
how is it a factor in employee burnout
great question we all know what it feels
like to be on a team where we are
offered psychological safety it means
that we can raise our hands and say I
made a mistake or I don't understand or
I've got some stuff going on at home and
it's affecting my work or I need help or
can you please be patient with me when
we can say these things
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution
um we can say these things without any
fear that will hurt our promotability
but more important we can say these
things with the confidence that those in
our team will rush in to support us or
our leaders will rush in to support us
and this is a huge factor for employee
burnout because when we feel that we can
say those things and we can feel
supported and we're more likely to seek
help for whatever is stressing us out or
causing us anxiety and more importantly
we don't feel alone as we're going
through the stress that's leading to
burnout so absolutely psychological
safety is a big part of helping reduce
employee burnout oh also
um psychological safety and providing
psychological safety is not just
something provided by our leaders it is
something provided by every member of
our team to other members of our team in
other words we're all responsible for
creating psychological safety for each
other
okay what do you do when you become the
leader you wish you had but you were
undermined by senior leadership that
doesn't support you okay so this is an
interesting question when you say you
become the leader you wish you had does
that mean you just got a promotion
because being the leader which you had
means you're operating in a way
um that you wish your leaders did and so
when you say being undermined there's a
few things to consider
like I used to joke you know the only
thing that all my failed relationships
have in common is me
um and so if if you feel you're
constantly being undermined
um is it the way in which maybe you're
presenting your worker or or conducting
yourself in front of your leaders
um are we making them are you making
them feel threatened so sometimes you
have to check in with yourself and say
is there something I can adapt here so
that maybe I can be better heard or
better better included in fact I saw it
recently I saw a guy walk into his
boss's office and with good intentions
start telling his boss everything he was
doing wrong well guess what the boss did
Wars went up and he couldn't hear it
because it's very hard to open a door
and just have somebody lambast you and
tell you everything you're doing wrong
so he may have felt that he was being
undermined but in reality I would
recommend that confronting his boss and
suggesting things that could be done
better maybe by starting by saying some
of the things that are going well would
be a better strategy but if you're truly
truly being undermined
um then can you have an effective
confrontation with your boss
the old FBI what is your feeling what
Behavior are they doing that makes you
feel that way and what impact does it
have it's a way to have an effective
confrontation you have to be really
really really specific you can't speak
in general like you always undermine me
you're always yelling at me so nothing's
going to get done that won't work what
you want to do is be really specific you
go into your boss and you say hey on
Thursday in the meeting that we had when
I made a suggestion of something we
could do you were very quick to push
back or throw out my idea and my fear is
is that if every time I have an idea in
a meeting and
um and you push back against it
um that eventually it's going to hurt
team morale and eventually it's going to
do damage to productivity
you say something like that and what FBI
is designed to do is allow the other
person to hear you and take
accountability so give it a try an
effective confrontation sometimes is the
way to go here's another one how do I
start a difficult conversation regarding
pay okay this one comes up more and more
and more and I've seen it screwed up so
many times where somebody comes in
and says
um I deserve this amount and these are
the reasons why or look how hard I've
been working I deserve money and very
often they put a number out there right
um and very often those when that
happens it's putting it's backing
somebody into a corner that allows no
room for in other words they're setting
up a yes or no which is very difficult
what I find is way more productive is to
talk to somebody and say may I talk to
you about my pay may I talked about my
compensation like set it up because
conversations about money are often very
uncomfortable so you're setting up an
uncomfortable conversation the leader
hopefully will say yes or they can
schedule a time so they know what what
it's about
um and then basically when you say is
um
um I you want to set up something about
feeling like you belong which is I
really like working here
um I want to stay here for a long time
um I and I'm learning a lot and I want
to continue learning and I also feel
that I've taken on more work for example
that may be the case or I've gone above
and beyond
um and I want to have a conversation
with you about
um the opportunities that I could have
that my compensation could reflect
um the additional work that I'm doing
can we talk about sort of what schedule
I can be put on and what goals I can
achieve with you in other words you
leave it slightly open-ended so it can
be a conversation and I'm you can have
numbers in your mind of what you'd like
to achieve that's totally fine but you
want to do is create a dialogue and very
often these conversations go south
because they become a demand rather than
a dialogue they become something that is
proposed as a yes or no and it becomes
much more heated and much more emotional
so give it a try try and make it a
dialogue where you can have a
conversation about how how to get on a
path to get more compensation in the
short medium and long term if you have
any additional questions that you would
like me to answer please put them in the
comments and I'll hope to get to some of
them in the near future thanks very much
take care of yourself take care of each
other